Speaker 1: Let's go to Topy. From the
Czech Republic. Toppy from the Czech
Republic. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: So nice to speak to you,
David. I'm currently a student from India studying
in Czech Republic. And I have a question regarding
why don't all the blue states in the U.S. sort of
come come together and launch their own version of
socialized health care instead of Radio National?
Speaker 1: There's a couple of issues right now.
I like the idea. I think it's more likely that the
right way to launch some kind of socialized health
care system is going to be within one state. Right
now, the difficulty with doing it in multiple
states is that in the United States, health care
is state by state. You. It's not as the term
that's often used. Toppy is health care isn't sold
across state lines. If you're in New York State,
you have to select from companies operating in New
York State and that are offering plans in New York
State. If you go to Florida, as I will be doing in
a few days, hopefully, and if I live in Florida,
I now need to choose from the plans made
available in Florida by companies licensed
in Florida. So it's difficult to immediately go
across state lines. What I would like to see is
one state to do a socialized health care system,
and then maybe they can grow it into a consortium
with neighboring states over time. But where
I'm 100% with you is states can start doing
this. And there was a failed attempt to get
it going in Vermont, which has its own kind
of back story. I would love to see this happen.
Speaker 3: No, I mean, like the we been in the EU,
our state and Jordan's from one
country is recognized across the EU.
Speaker 1: Yes. I would love to see that.
It requires a bunch of regulatory and other
changes. But I'm with you. I would love to see it.
Speaker 3: And quickly, a second question. Sure.
If you you have been transparent that
you invest in Amazon. But wouldn't you,
like push for something more sustainable, Like
instead of us progressives putting money in
companies that we don't really align with?
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. I mean, listen,
it's so first of all, in terms of my individual
stocks, I've divested myself from just about every
individual stock I had. So, you know, I previously
invested in Alphabet and Live Nation and Tesla
and Amazon and, you know, all the I've mostly sold
almost all my individual stocks. But the truth is,
like even through index funds, I am invested in
little pieces of companies that I don't directly,
you know, that I don't support, whose business
models I don't support. And that's an unfortunate
reality. You know, Noam Chomsky was asked about
this as well, and someone confronted him and said,
you know, you criticize a lot of these fossil
fuel companies, but you're invested in index
funds and so you own a little bit of them. And
Chomsky was kind of just flippantly like, well,
why should I keep my money under my mattress
instead? Or something like that? I think you
bring up a totally fair point. But it it there
are limits to what people can do, and not every
action everyone takes is ever going to be 100%
aligned with every moral principle. And, you know,
the the simplest thing for me to be able to do the
best show I can and to focus on the show is I keep
my investments in really low cost index funds
where I own the entire total stock market index
and there will be some companies in there I don't
like, but I'm going to do more good by by leaving
the money there and then simply focusing on the
show. It does. Does that make sense in any way?
Speaker 3: Yeah, no. I mean, last semester I took
some courses and this university in Germany was
incredibly leftwing. And the way they do is they
try and push their students to introduce students
to companies that are more sustainable overall.
So instead of investing in mainstream companies,
you invest there, like in the U.S., you have
gravity payments. And the CEO was incredibly,
incredibly popular because he did he was his
salary and is pretty much the same as his
coworkers. So in Western companies like that.
Speaker 1: That is that is perfectly fair.
That is absolutely fair. And I think that's
completely reasonable, what you're saying.
I am, you know, guilty as charged.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Okay. All right.
Speaker 1: My friend Toppy, thank
you very much. I appreciate it.